safety is really top of mind as a
hundred and seventy thousand people
prepared to attend life is beautiful
festival it's coming up this weekend
it's a three-day festival and it's going
to have strict guidelines when it comes
to covid kate houston breaks down the
protocols and also the convenient
solutions that are going to be available
unvaccinated or partially vaccinated
attendees must have a negative cova 19
test to get in starting at 9 a.m
tomorrow they can come here for a 15
minute rapid test at a discounted price
i feel like everybody is being very
safe and doing their due diligence as
far as covid goes festival attendees
like alexis vigil are preparing for the
return of life is beautiful having that
being gone for so long and being able
for it to come back the way that it is
i'm so excited this year attendees must
provide proof of full vaccination or a
negative covit 19 test the clear app is
the fastest way to show vaccination
status this is albert lucero's sixth
year going to the festival and he has
his clear app ready to go as i said it
there's a different line for it so
that line's a lot quicker than
the line that you normally get in then
i'd rather just go through the shortcut
he thinks in hopes many will wear a mask
if you're not vax mask up even if you
are vax mascot those not using the clear
app or those showing a negative test
have other options attendees will need
to bring an id and either the original
vaccination card or a printed copy or
photo of the card or negative test
at-home tests are not accepted kate
houston 8 news now
we can also tell you that the i heart
radio music festival that's happening
this weekend too proof of vaccination or
negative test is also required and masks
are going to be required inside
regardless of your vaccination status